und einen wald apfel gehört ihr schon
der zittert und der macht komische
geräusche und der will sich jetzt zurück
verwandelt hallöchen meine lieben
freunde und herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge der minecraft fakes ich muss
mich heute ein wenig beeilen weil ich
gleich meinen zug erwischen muss nach
köln weil ich mit maxi kran kraft und
justin kelly pixel gold nach köln fahren
weil wir einfach spontan dachten hey
lasst mal nach köln fahren ich habe mir
wieder 56 rausgesucht wenn ihr auch
einen kühleffekt habt würde ich mich
sehr freuen wenn ihr den einfach unten
in die kommentare schreiben würde weil
dann können die untereinander darüber
diskutieren und so weiter und so fort
ich würde mich freuen wenn wir bis zum
ende dran bleibt und anfang an mit fett
nummer direkt nummer eins wurde mir
zugesendet von killer muffins so schock
so steht irgendwie für couscous oder im
gesicht es nicht verstand wieso ist
sowieso steht wenn man zwei verzauberte
schwerter nebeneinander ins crafting
feld liegt erhält man ein nicht
verzauberte schwert ich hoffe du hast
kannst etwas wie kann ich lesen
ich kann nicht lesen ich war zauber hier
ein holzschwert auf plünderung 3 und
dann packe ich dann noch einen
holzschnitt rhein auch auf plünderung
drei dann stelle ich mir neben ein
crafting table und normalerweise müssten
die jetzt zusammen irgendwie zu einem
normalen auch irgendwie plünderungen
drei werden oder irgendwie so aber es
wird zu einem normalen holz schwer als
auch komplett egal ob ich damit jetzt
noch irgendwelche tiere tötet oder
irgendwann ja es ist auch komplett egal
ob ich damit in welche tiere töten da
irgendwie sowas also irgendwie wenn das
schwert dann benutzt oder so das macht
überhaupt keinen unterschied das seht
ihr nämlich jetzt mal eben zwar lege ich
dir jetzt einfach wieder nebeneinander
hier rein und ich bekomme ein ganz
normales holzschwert genau das gleiche
ist wenn ich das einfach hier in meinem
crafting fällt dir packe krieg auch ein
ganz normales holz etwas einfach ein
total dummer tausch ist und was
eigentlich auch gar keinen sinn ergibt
aber das perfekt nummer 12 effekt wurde
mir zugesendet von simon und zwar
schreibt er wenn man eine plünderung
schwerter bekommt man ja von mobs mehr
items und man kann das ganze auch mit
dem bogen machen wenn du mit dem bogen
auf einen mob schießen und kurz bevor
der pfeil ankommt auf das plünderung
schwert wechselt hat
bogen praktisch den gleichen effekt die
entbündelung schwert ich habe hier ein
diamant schwert mit plünderungen 3 und
natürlich wenn ich damit jetzt irgendwie
ein schwein getötet ihr schon da bekomme
ich einfach mal fünf rohes
schweinefleisch das schon ganz geil aber
wenn ich jetzt mit dem bogen abschieds
und ihr seht schon ich wünsche einfach
direkt auf die einst seht ihr schon auch
wenn ich jetzt hingehen ich habe gerade
viel rohes schweinefleisch dazu gekommen
dass auch überdurchschnittlich viel
essig zeigt euch noch mal wenn ich jetzt
einfach mal hier den hier abschließe so
einmal abgeschossen und raten wir warten
erst mal wieder bis der dich beruhigt
von mentschows schießt den normal ab und
switche direkt auf die eins und ihr seht
schon jetzt wenn ich das hier ein sammel
da waren auch drei schweinefleisch was
man eigentlich sonst nie von einem
sparschwein bekommt jetzt nämlich
beispielsweise mal ihm hier eben und
jetzt ist er einfach weg und lege mich
wo ich der oder ist das derivate und ich
hab's gesehen ich hab ganz schnell
gewechselt und jetzt habe ich noch mal
ein paar fleisch schweinefleisch dazu
bekommen also ihr könnt quasi euer
schwert müsst ihr dafür gar nicht
benutzen sondern ihr könnt einfach wenn
ihr den bogen mit dem bogen jemanden
töten wollte irgendwie aus entfernen und
müsste nicht extra hin laufen sondern
können auch einfach schnell auf das
schwert zwischen um damit auch in die
plünderungen ran zu kommen die durch
diese schwer quasi verspricht also
plünderung 1 2 oder 3
das wurde mir zugesendet von simon allen
danke an die klima- und top banker so
freunde der dritte weg wurde mir
zugesendet von tdi und zwar schreibt er
habe zwei oder mehr oder weniger toll
effekts für dich erstes wenn du aus der
luft auf eine seerose die im wasser
liegt springst erscheint wasser partikel
ich hab nur den ersten angenommen weil
ich habe gesagt pro person höchstens so
einen effekt auf das sind extrem cool
effect einfach damit die anderen auch
noch mal drankommen zwar ihr seht schon
wenn ich jetzt hier aus einer etwas
höheren höhe auf die seerose drauf
springe seht ihr das und wasser partikel
allerdings ist mir aufgefallen
das gleiche passiert auch bei irgend
welchen teppichen und zwar wenn jetzt
immer runter falle seht ihr schon da
kommen auch wasser partikel man kann
teppiche eh nur mit einem kleinen trick
auf dem wasser platzieren teppich auf
dem wasser ziehen zu können müsste die
quasi erst so setzt und dann genau hier
gegen drücken damit den am teppich
platziert weil wenn ich hier
beispielsweise einfach mal drauf klicken
damit er halt direkt dies bauen das aber
nur eine kleine sache am rande und zwar
ist es ganz einfach so dass ich letztens
auch schon mal gezeigt hatte dass wenn
man weit von einem block entfernt
wenn ich hier auf die kante hatte ich ja
schon mal gezeigt wenn ich jetzt runter
fallen
seht ihr auch da kommen wasser partikel
vielleicht einfach mehr auf diesem blog
bereits auf dem anderen
und bei diesen blöcken ist das so die
sind einfach mehr die sind noch kleiner
als die hälfte von dem blog deswegen
passiert das ganze hier dass ich wenn
ich jetzt drauf springen wasser partikel
bekomme und hier bekomme ich ebenfalls
wasser partikel obwohl ich ja eigentlich
auf die seerose beziehungsweise den
teppich drauf springen bisschen komisch
sollte auch eigentlich mal ich finde das
sollte eigentlich geändert werden das
ist sind halt wird von minecraft ich
meinen die seerose geht nicht mehr so
richtig als block angesehen sondern die
liegt quasi unter dem wasser sogar der
teppich liegt noch ein bisschen darüber
wenn ihr euch mal diese schwarzen
striche anschaut aber trotzdem
eigentlich ein bisschen eine komische
sache das war jedenfalls 3 dank endlich
tdci freunde ihr seht schon es regnet
und ja dieser regen hat etwas mit fact
nummer vier zu tun und zwar ist das
einfach eine sache die mir so ein
bisschen aufgefallen ist und zwar habe
ich einfach mal als geregnet habe einen
ganz normalen rumprobieren in minecraft
einfach mal so ein bisschen angezündet
und zwar das feuer wenn ihr das seht ich
habe ja jetzt in dieser reihenfolge hier
angezündet das brennt auch in dieser
reihenfolge zurück am besten ist es wenn
ich wirklich mal eine reihe mache da
seht ihr die reihe brennt nach und nach
zurück am besten vielleicht noch zu
sehen wenn ich das hier so von der seite
mache seht ihr die gehen nacheinander
aus also nicht jetzt irgendwie
zeitversetzt sondern die gehen alle
zeitgleich ausgewichen das ist hier so
eine linie wie die ausgehen
das hat einfach etwas damit zu tun und
zwar feuer brennt genau wenn es regnet
zwischen 1 7 und 2 sekunden also ich hab
wirklich das 20 mal getestet habe mein
handy genommen stopp weil sich das feuer
geklickt habe und stoppe wieder drauf
gedrückt wo es ausgegangen ist war immer
zwischen 1 7 und 2 sekunden und zwar
werde ich euch das jetzt auch einfach
mal einblenden damit ihr da so ein
kleiner vergleich qualität um mir das
auch glaubt
ja meine lieben freunde da habt ihr die
zeit das ist jetzt irgendwo zwischen 1 7
und 2 sekunden später einfügen aber es
sind auf jeden fall zwischen 17 und zwei
sekunden sein irgendwo also manchmal 17
3 181 die beiden ergebnis hatte ich sehr
oft und das ist quasi immer so lange wie
das feuer quasi bei regen überlebt das
wäre natürlich extrem cool wenn sie mich
hat auch so wäre wenn irgendwas anfing
zu brennen und es regnet und noch bis zu
zwei sekunden ist einfach alles gelöscht
es wäre natürlich schon cool in
minecraft derzeit nur 17 bis zwei
sekunden
und das war rektor numero firo der mit
zugesendet wurde von miro miro miro
klose familie von nicht von mir egal
gibt wo freunde effekt nummer 5 wurde
mir zugesendet von fresh up und zwar
schreibt der schweizer einen villiger
zombie mit einem schwächelt rang ab und
führte ihn dann mit einem gold apfel
dann beginnt er zu zittern und wird zu
einem normalen zombie dann berichte ich
ihn allerdings der manic roboter
schreibt er wirklich zu einem normalen
zombie er wird zum village und das ist
nummer führen wenn ich jetzt einfach mal
so ein paar zombies porno hoffe ich
einfach dass irgendwann mal so ein
williger zombie dabei ist das
dauerticket ksa kopf wieso lava ich kopf
guckt meine ich da ist alle gucken mich
an diesen behinderten spaten älter na ja
und zwar das ist ein billiger tommy dass
er daran dass der sonnen villiger skin
hat aber dann mit diesem komischen
welchen augen drin und wenn ich jetzt
diesen will ja mit einem werk waren
krank der schwäche abwerfe und einem
wald apfel gehört ihr schon der zittert
und der macht komische geräusche und der
will sicher zurückverwandelt minecraft
forum steht man soll den einen verfahren
trank der schwäche geben oder so und ein
gold apfel und dann zittern die halt so
ein bisschen aber ich kann euch das auch
normal zeigen hier
und dann verwandelte er sich quasi
zeitversetzt zurücksteht in minecraft
worum ich weiß nicht genau was in
minecraft wiki beziehungsweise forum
damit gemeint ist mit zeitversetzt oder
so weil ich habe noch keine veränderung
davon gesehen aber angeblich
funktioniert halt bei allen und ich
denke dass ich irgendwie an mir oder ich
habe das irgendwie falsch verstanden auf
jeden fall verwandelt sich dieser wille
dazu mir zeitversetzt zurück in seine
vorfahren oder irgendwie sowas also in
villiger er hatte erst geschrieben der
fresh der erst geschrieben er verwandelt
sich in einen normalen zombie das stimmt
aber land allerdings nicht sondern er
verwandelt sich zurück in einen village
und man kann quasi machen das will
jobkomm ließ sich zurück weil man ihn
einfach mit einem wert bei antrag der
schwäche gibt und dann mit einem gold
apfel futter so freunde das wasser noch
spieler mit dem minecraft fakes ich
hoffe euch hat es gefallen wenn es euch
gefallen hat würde ich mich über eine
bewertung freund oben münster gefahren
ich werde jetzt mit metallen jetten nach
köln fahren und da werden mir bisschen
channel ein bisschen mitmachen keine
ahnung und wenn ihr wollt dass ich da so
ein bisschen filme mit den beiden jungs
oder noch mit anderen youtube an die wir
da eventuell auch noch sehen oder so
dann zeigt es mir auch mit der bewertung
unterschreibt den kommentaren dann werde
ich da von morgen irgendwie sonntag in
köln und dahingehend hochladen und dann
sehen wir uns da wieder typisch